♪ ♪
>> Greg: EYE CANDY CALLED TWIX
SERVES UP A WOKE FIX.
IN PARTNERSHIP WITH 20TH DIGITAL
STUDIO GRADE THE TWO MINUTE
SHORT FILM CALLED THE NEW NANNY,
ALL ABOUT A GOTHIC WITCH WHO
SHOWS UP AT A YOUNG BOY'S DOOR
OFFERING TO BE HIS NEW NANNY AND
IT'S NOT LONG BEFORE SHE BREWS
UP SOME CONTROVERSY.
>> WIRE DRESSED UP?
IT'S NOT HALLOWEEN YET.
CAN I HELP YOU?
>> ARE YOU A GOOD WITCH OR A BAD
WITCH?
>> DO YOU WANT TO FIND OUT?
>> I'M STILL WEARING MY
PRINCESS ADDRESS.
>> DO YOU WANT TO WEAR IT?
>> Greg: NO ONE ASKED ME IF I
BUCKLED UP IF I WANT TO WEAR MY
PRINCESS ADDRESS.
THANKS FOR NOTHING,
AMERICAN AIRLINES.
IF YOUR NANNY SHOWS UP TO WORK
ON THE FIRST DAY WITH A
HALLOWEEN COSTUME YOU MIGHT WANT
TO RAISE YOUR OWN KIDS.
BUT LET'S GET WOKE.
>> YOU LOOK LIKE A GIRL, WHY ARE
YOU WEARING THEM?
>> DRESSING LIKE THIS MAKES ME
FEEL GOOD TO.
>> IS THAT YOUR NANNY?
SHE LOOKS WEIRD, YOU GUYS ARE
BOTH WEIRD.
>> WERE JUST DRESSED DIFFERENT.
>> WHERE IS IT COMING FROM?
WHAT'S HAPPENING?
HELP!
>> WILL HE COME BACK?
PROBABLY.
>> Greg: IF THERE'S ANYTHING A
CHILD CAN TRUST FOR GOOD ADVICE,
IT'S A GOTHIC BABYSITTER.
I CAN'T WAIT FOR PART TWO WHEN
SHE TEACHES HOW TO SHOPLIFT AT
HOT TOPIC.
WHY IS TWIX LECTURING US ON
GENDER IDENTITY, WHO DID THEY
THINK THEY ARE?
SNICKERS?
CANDY BAR COMPANIES MAKE A
HALLOWEEN AD THAT HAS NOTHING TO
DO WITH CANDY, THEY ARE WEIGHING
IN ON SOCIAL ISSUES INSTEAD OF
THE WEIGHT OF THEIR SUGAR
ADDICTED CUSTOMERS.
IF YOU THOUGHT THAT SHORT FILM
WAS BAD YOU SHOULD'VE SEEN THEIR
ORIGINAL VERSION.
>> HI, I'M CHARLIE,
TRICK-OR-TREAT, GIVE ME SOME
CANDY.
>> I'M NOT GOING TO GIVE YOU
CANDY COME I'M GOING TO GIVE YOU
SOMETHING MUCH MORE VALUABLE.
LIFE LESSONS.
LIFE IS A DAILY PROCESS OF
DISAPPOINTMENT WHERE YOU LEARN
TO EAT [BLEEP] 1 TEASPOON AT A
TIME, AFTER A WHILE YOU DON'T
EVEN NOTICE THE TASTE.
THEN YOU WILL DEVELOP AN
ADDICTION TO DRUGS, ALCOHOL,
POSSIBLY AND BY POSSIBLY COME
I'M INDEFINITELY AND BEFORE YOU
KNOW WHAT, YOUR WIFE HAS LEFT
YOU, YOUR KIDS HATE YOUR GUTS
AND YOU'RE WONDERING WHAT THE
WHOLE POINT OF EXISTENCE WAS IN
THE FIRST PLACE.
THAT ENOUGH OF A TREAT FOR YOU?
>> Greg: I'VE PROCREATED WITH
SEVERAL DIFFERENT WOMEN, I HAVE
A SMALL LITTER OF CHILDREN THAT
I RAISED.
WE HAVE ESTABLISHED IT NOW AND I
ALLOW THEM TO GET TREATS BECAUSE
THE MORE THEY GET ADDICTED TO
SUGAR, THEY FALL ASLEEP FASTER.
WHAT BLOWS MY MIND -- I KNOW YOU
WANT TO TALK ABOUT BUT WHAT
BLOWS MY MIND IS THERE WASN'T A
TWIX IN THE WHOLE COMMERCIAL.
AT LEAST TURN THE KID WHO WAS
ASKING QUESTIONS INTO A CANDY
BAR INSTEAD OF BLOWING HIM OFF
INTO OBLIVION.
>> Greg: THEY MURDERED HIM!
>> THEY DIDN'T MURDER HIM, THEY
PURPOSELY AT THE END OF THE AD,
WILL HE BE BACK?
YES, HE'LL BE BACK.
>> THEY BURNED THE WITCH, THAT
IS THE RIGHT TWIX COMMERCIAL
THEY ARE ACTING LIKE KIDS
WEARING DRESSES AND BEING
DIFFERENT HAPPEN TWO WEEKS AGO,
THIS HAS GONE ON FOREVER.
IN MY NEIGHBORHOOD, WE HAD ONE
OF THE KIDS IN MY NEIGHBORHOOD
THAT DRESSED LIKE A LITTLE GIRL,
WE DIDN'T BEAT HIM UP AND PICK
ON HIM, THE ONLY TIME WE GOT MAD
AT HIM IS WHEN HE WOULD PLAY
HIDE AND SEEK TO GO KIDS THE
MOST FORGIVING GROUP.
I WEAR DRESSES WHERE IT MAKES ME
FEEL GOOD, WHY DO YOU WEAR A
CAPE, I WANT TO BE A SUPERHERO.
10 MINUTES LATER THEY ARE
PLAYING SOCCER UNTIL THE WITCH
JUMPS IN.
THE MESSAGES IF SOMEONE IS
DIFFERENT FROM YOU AND ASKS
QUESTIONS, YOU GOT TO KILL THEM.
SPEAKING OF THAT, REVERSE IT,
HE'S DIFFERENT FROM ME, HE'S
WEARING A DRESS.
HERE IS TYRUS THE WARLOCK, THAT
KID IS DIFFERENT, DON'T WORRY I
HAPPENED TO HAVE MY DIFFERENT
ARROW RIGHT HERE, IS HE GOING TO
LIVE?
I DON'T KNOW, MAYBE.
>> Greg: KIDS GROW OUT OF
STUFF.
>> KIDS ARE CRAZY, I REMEMBER IF
A KID PLAYED WITH BARBIE DOLLS,
HE WOULD GET BEAT UP.
YOU AIN'T ONE OF US, KIDS WERE
CRAZY BACK THEN.
WHATEVER YOU DID DIFFERENT BUT
IT REMINDED ME OF THE BRIAN
DEPALMA SEEN IN CARY, HE FALLS
OFF THE BICYCLE.
MY WASN'T TOO OFFENDED BY IT.
THE WOKE THING WITH THE
COMMERCIALS, WHY DID THEY DO IT?
YOU SEE WHY, THEY TALK ABOUT IT
NOW, YOU GO ON TWITTER YOU HAVE
PEOPLE OUTRAGED, PEOPLE SAYING
IT'S THE MOST PEOPLE THEY
NEVER EVER SEEN IN THE LIFE.
THAT'S WHAT THEY WANT AND
DOESN'T SELL THE CANDY BAR?
PROBABLY NOT BUT WE ARE TALKING
ABOUT A CANDY BAR NOBODY'S
TALKING ABOUT NOW.
>> Greg: LOOK AT THE SHAPE OF
TWIX, WHAT DOES IT REMIND YOU
OF?
I WILL GO THERE.
ISN'T TWIX AND ANTIFEMALE CANDY?
>> THOSE SKINNY --
>> Greg: THAT IS --
>> THAT'S NOT WHAT TWIX EVER
REMINDED ME OF.
>> Greg: HERE'S MY ISSUE WITH
THIS.
CLEARLY ADULTS PITCHED THIS IDEA
AND WROTE IT, IT'S NOT A REAL
STORY, IS NOT AN ORGANIC
EXPERIENCE, IT'S MANUFACTURED TO
BECAUSE YOU COULDN'T FIND THIS
STORY IN REALITY ERGO THEN YOU
HIRE KIDS TO PLAY THESE ROLES
THAT ADULTS CREATE.
THIS IS NOT COMMON, AND YET THEY
ARE TRYING TO CONVEY A MESSAGE
THAT IT IS COMMON BECAUSE THEY
SELL A PRODUCT THAT KILLS
PEOPLE, RIGHT?
>> I WAS INCREDIBLY ANDROGYNOUS
LOOKING FOR SEVERAL YEARS AS A
CHILD.
>> Greg: THAT'S AN
UNDERSTATEMENT.
>> THAT'S NOT A JOKE, THAT IS A
FACT.
>> Greg: SHE LOOKED LIKE THE
SECOND BASEMAN FROM THE ORIGINAL
BAD NEW BEARS.
>> I ALSO WOULD WEAR ONLY
FLANNEL, I WAS LIKE I WANTED TO
LOOK LIKE KURT COBAIN.
PEOPLE WOULD MAKE FUN OF ME, BUT
I'M FINE.
I DIDN'T NEED A WITCH TO COME
USE THE POWERS OF SATAN TO
MURDER MY CLASSMATES.
>> ONE THING I DID SEE ABOUT THE
COMMERCIAL WAS THE FIRST PERSON
TO CRITIQUE THEM AND THIS THEM
WAS A BLACK GIRL, A LOT OF TIMES
THEY GENERATE THIS THING, BLACK
PEOPLE HATE THE MOST HOMOPHOBIC,
YOU'RE DRESSED LIKE A WOMAN,
LET'S CAST A BLACK GIRL.
>> IF YOU SELL CANDY, YOU DON'T
HAVE TO WEIGH INTO THESE TOUCHY
TOPICS.
>> Greg: THIS IS ALL BLEEDING
IN FROM ACADEMIA, THEY ARE ALL
HUMAN RESOURCES NOW.
THE HYPOCRISY IS THAT SUGAR IS
WORSE FOR KIDS THAN ANYTHING --
IT'S WORSE FOR ADULTS.
DIABETES, ITS OBESITY, IT MAKES
THEM VERY SLEEPY AND THEY WAKE
UP AND THEY ARE VERY OBNOXIOUS.
YOU KNOW WHAT I'M GETTING AT.
IT'S MEANT AS A DIVERSIONARY
TACTIC FROM CRITIQUING WHAT THEY
ACTUALLY DO.
>> THERE'S NO DOUBT WHAT IS
GOING ON THERE IS YOU ARE
SELLING POISON TO CHILDREN IN A
WAY THAT WILL BE ENTERTAINING,
THERE ARE A MILLION WAYS TO DO
THAT.
THE CANDY IS GOOD TO MAKE YOU
POPULAR, TO TELL YOU THE TRUTH
IN THE WORLD I LIVE IN THEIR ART
OF GREAT NONBINARY KIDS AND I
CAN IMAGINE IF I WERE TRYING TO
BE PRAGMATIC AND SELL CANDY I
WOULD HAVE A COMMERCIAL LIKE
THAT BECAUSE THAT IS A NEW
SENSIBILITY.
ULTIMATELY THIS IS SOMETHING
THAT KILLS YOU AND THERE IS THE
IDEA THAT THERE IS PROGRESSIVISM
THAT'S BEING PUSHED ALONG WITH
THAT, THAT'S WEIRD.
>> Greg: I WOULD BOYCOTT
[BLEEP].
BOYCOTT TWIX!
>> I LOVE AND SUPPORT YOU NO
MATTER WHAT.
>> MY LOVE DOES NOT RUN THAT
DEEP.
>> Greg: I LIKE THE MIX OF
CHOCOLATE AND CARAMEL AND
COOKIE.
>> WE KNOW YOU LIKE TWIX.
LET'S JUST MOVE ALONG.
>> Greg: ANOTHER HALLOWEEN
STORY, WIL